not everything you see on the Internet
is like real life you know you're
following your favorite Instagram or
whatever at that to not strive to be
that because they're not even that
[Music]
remind me did Kendall chop your bank
yeah she said we're going to the play
house she drank scissors
we got in the play house and she's just
started cutting my hair off all of my
whole head I were you thinking like I
just listened to her to choose with my
older sister I just remember you guys
being very girly girls
you loved my makeup and I used to have a
lucite and you got older the lucite
makeup thing and it was full of makeup
you know week after week I could see
straight through it
you know because you would take my
makeup out of it and not return it yeah
you never got mad though I don't
remember any memories of you like that's
just you know what you do when you're a
mom and you have kids that are obsessed
with makeup you just let it go and look
at you now
now you're loaning me makeup you're so
generous with your bags
that's because I love you
when someone gets older I think it's
really important to remind ourselves
that it's really great to get up in the
morning and put your best foot forward
and look your best because then you'll
feel your best this summer I was redoing
my house so I was living with you for
like two months we're not doing anything
by the way the house and to see her get
up and get fully dressed full makeup
just looks so glam while I like was in
sweats and like I'm like mammarra doing
anything today but she always looked
just Sheila always looks like so perfect
and put together every day and that is
my goal
I think what I learned from you
especially as I got older you taught me
how to have a fresher look and you also
taught me how to do a great lip like I
was so stuck in doing the same makeup
all the time because I got lazy and you
really gave me a whole new fresh
perspective on how to do my makeup you
guys would always be so excited to go
somewhere and I remember I focused first
on your hair and I cut down half-up
half-down or you know the big bows it
was always about the bow one time we
were getting ready and you decided to
make sure your fish were clean and you
put some soap in their water and they
didn't make it very long that night I
know you were so cute I was doing your
hair and you were putting soap in the
fish bowl
and he didn't stop me well I didn't see
it because I was so into the hair but it
was really funny I mean not funny
because they passed away
[Music]
I want to know where this like iconic
hairstyle came like I know you've always
really had short hair like a pixie cut
like that is aren't even if folks coats
like the Kris Jenner cut but that is
like really daring like I would just I
couldn't feel like I would just never
could do that really good looks I'm not
going to say never see cut when I was 30
years old the perm was in don't ever
just don't do a permanent we thought
earlier straight
it was curly and we thought we were so
cool like we got a perm and I thought I
was killing it and it was awful and then
I finally decided my hairdresser Alex
Roldan said let's cut your hair it'll
look so great and we did and it was like
the best thing I ever did
[Music]
now in the internet we have such a
breach and you just see so many
different like beautiful bodies and
everyone like embracing their body when
I went through such a body change
recently with like pregnancy and like
saw my body in like a whole new way and
then here we yeah there's two on a super
young age and just like my body's still
not the same but I just feel like just
loving like every stage and just like
appreciating all different types of
bodies not everything you see on the
Internet is like real life
nobody has like a perfect life or a
perfect body or perfect anything so I
think just to remember when you you know
you're following your favorite Instagram
or whatever at that to not strive to be
that because they're not even that it's
just I'm not evolving in time on my
Instagram post my favorite photos of
myself and my best photos or whatever
but there's so many other angles of me
I really feel like everybody needs to
spread a little more positivity and I
worry about stormy and my grandchildren
and you know growing up in a you know a
place where on all these different
social media platforms that there is the
ability to be an anonymous bully and
just say whatever you want unfiltered
that's the downside of it the upside is
there's so much to learn and there's so
much to you know to gain but that that
little bit of negativity you know you
don't want that to spread or go too far
like I hope that they can contain that
or people just start being a little more
positive and and lift each other up
rather than tear each other down I think
that what's gotten me through negativity
is just I have a really thick skin yeah
you know so I just want to teach Storme
to have really yakun because yeah
something that'll it that will get you
through you can't control you know
you're right
you